Next we'll have the Office of Fleet Management.
Keep looking around the room for Jack Christie for this one, but I don't think
he's here's.
I'd like to welcome Director Gary Glask
and Mr. Ray Cruz. Good afternoon.
My name is Gary Glaskok, and I'm the director of the Fleet Management
Department. I'll be presenting the department's proposed operating
budget for fiscal year 2023.
Along with me is Ray Cruz of the Finance Department.
Ray serves as the Chief Financial Officer
for Fleet Management. Next slide, please.
I'll start with some department information for reference purposes.
Our mission is to provide the City of Houston with best value fleet
management services. We operate 27 maintenance garages
and 67 refueling sites to service a little more
than 13,700 vehicles and pieces of
equipment. Next slide, please.
Fleet Management is a revolving fund department.
Our proposed operating budget for fiscal year 2023
is $98,930,411.
This budget will provide for a little more than 381
full time positions that are deployed within five
different programs. The first of these programs is
the Director's Office, which handles the strategic planning,
policy making and personnel administration for the department.
The budget of the Director's Office covers restricted account charges
by other city departments, including Human Resources,
Finance and Hits. Our Operation division
performs the maintenance work in the garages and oversees
the repair work done by our contractors. 61% of
the total Fleet Management budget is allocated to the
operations program to cover the cost of labor,
spare parts and contracted services.
The Fuel Management Group oversees fuel,
inventories and service station maintenance. Their budget
pays for the gasoline and diesel used by city vehicles.
Our Customer Service Division handles the distribution of replacement parts,
our material and services contracts, as well as our motor
pool or fleet share. The customer service budget
is largely driven by labor costs.
And then finally, our Asset Management Division oversees
capital, program, vehicle, onboarding tracking
and eventual disposal. They also manage our data collection
system as well as our reporting systems. In addition to
labor costs, the asset management budget covers software,
maintenance and related expenses. Next slide,
please. This slide
provides historical reference for our proposed budget and major expense categories.
Again, we are a revolving fund department, so the
listed values reflect both our revenues and expenses.
In the top table, you'll see that we're proposing a $3.9
million or 4.2% increase in operating expenses
compared to current year. Moving down
to the expense category table, our personnel expenses
are increasing by 3.6%, while the cost
of supplies is going up $1.8 million or
9%. We're seeing a 1%
increase in restricted account charges as well as an increase
of $535,000 for contracted
services. And I'll provide a little more detail on these increases a
little later in the presentation. Next slide, please.
Here's a graphical representation on how the funding of our
proposed budget is being allocated. Labor is
the largest slice of the pie at 37% of total,
followed by fuel at 25% and parts.
At 16%, we plan to spend roughly $9
million on Outsider Contracted Services and
$5.6 million on tires.
The $4.1 million slice of pie labeled Other Restricted
accounts includes what we pay other city departments for their
services. And finally, the 3 million in the other miscellaneous
expenses will fund items such as office supplies,
employee uniforms, diagnostic software and tools.
Next slide, please.
Fleet Management receives revenues from our client departments to
cover their fuel and vehicle maintenance expenses.
Roughly 74 million in revenue will be sourced from the general fund
departments, while 23 million is expected from the departments
that operate with enterprise funds. Another 2.8
million will come from special grants and funds.
Next slide.
This table lists the expenditure changes included in the proposed budget
compared to current year. In the top section of the table, you'll see that our
operating budget for fiscal year 22 is $94.9 million.
This amount includes a $4.6 million
adjustment that was made to cover fuel price increases.
The middle section of the table highlights the significant adjustments of
the proposed fiscal year 23 budget. All of
the increases are limited to contractual or mandated
adjustments. The sum of these adjustments results
in the 4.2% budget increase compared
to current year. Next slide, please.
Here's some additional detail on the budget adjustments of the
previous slide. Personnel costs are going up approximately
$997,000 due to the Hope salary
increase along with the rising costs of health and pension benefits.
Our headcount for fiscal year 23 actually drops by
three compared to current year. Fuel expenses
go up $240,000. This increases
on top of the $4.6 million adjustment that
was made to the current year budget for fuel.
A $2 million Escalation for the purchase of parts will
cover rising costs resulting from inflation and supply
chain issues. We're also increasing the cost of contracted services
by $1 million. This adjustment will handle Escalating contractor
rates as well as provide us with some additional contracting capacity.
The $379,000 reduction in program
expenses is a sum of cuts over multiple budget
line items as well as the elimination of onetime
expenses that occurred during the current year.
And this concludes the Fleet Management Fiscal Year 2023 budget
presentation. We've got next slide there, but I think we'll
skip over it for the sake of time. Really isn't related to the budget,
and we'll go to questions. Thank you,
Council Member Ed Pollard. Thank you, Chair. I have a couple of
questions. First one is from Council Member Michael Kubash,
who's not with us at the moment. His question
is how do we purchase gasoline,
diesel and CNG? Do we buy it
each month or is there a contract out for it each year?
We purchase it under contract and we're currently in the third
year of the contract. We've got two one year options that
are available. The current term
ends, I believe it's in September of this year.
And that vendor is for all different types of gasoline.
No, we've actually got one vendor for gasoline
and another vendor for diesel.
And we actually ride the contract
that's owned by Metro. And so Metro's
fuel Buying, in addition to the City's fuel buying, provides us with some purchasing
leverage. Second question is,
last year we had a budget amendment that was put forth that
we discussed within BFA that talked about the
idea of putting advertisements on city
vehicles as a way to generate revenue. I knew we were doing
maybe a study or an analysis on whether or not that is feasible,
something that would be attractive to the city. Are you familiar with that?
Where do we stand on that? I was not involved in those particular
discussions, but I can say that at a previous employer,
we did take advantage of that particular opportunity and there was
some revenue that was generated. Of course, this was using transit
buses. So there's a much larger canvas compared to the
opportunities that are provided with city vehicles. Chair, did we ever
get any feedback on that after we did that BFA meeting
regarding that topic? No, not that I recall.
Okay, I'll follow up with you on that. Thank you. This is a quick follow
up. The contracts for the gas, diesel and LNG,
are they a fixed price or a variable? They're variable price and they're
based on the Platts marketing index. And so our price
is relative to whatever that index is doing. So as prices
rise we didn't do any hedging. We did not do any hedging,
but we are considering it at the moment. In fact,
we've had some discussions with both our finance group and legal
as well as Metro because they're doing a little hedging right now to see
if we can offer the city some protection going that route.
Council member Amy Peck. Thank you. Thank you, Director,
for the presentation. As costs are
increasing for gas, for just maintenance, for everything
related to fleet, how closely are you working with the
departments when they're looking at their budgets? Are you telling them, here's what we
can expect for increase in costs and then they're doing their budget accordingly?
Or are they just kind of left up to determining how much those costs might
go up? Yes, we work with the departments regularly
and we're actually seeing some unprecedented times.
And so we're seeing some really high
increase for the cost of vehicles.
We're also seeing high increases for parts, but we're also seeing
supply chain issues. And so what used to take six
months to get is now taking up to 1824
months for delivery. And so what we're asking our departments
to do is to focus on the critical vehicles in their shift within
their fleet because they're much harder to get compared
to previous. And so that's where our attention
is at the moment. Thank you. Council Member Sally Alcorn,
along those same lines as Council Member Peck, I noticed in the
budget book you've got under fuel management there's a decrease,
$3 million in that division.
So I don't know if that's just because of when we
were okay,
so there was a decrease made relative to
the current year budget. My understanding is
that based on fuel prices, when we put the budget together,
the cost of fuel is actually much less than what it currently
is. We've had a spike since then. Will you probably make an adjustment to
this? Because that did catch my eyes when I was looking at the divisions and
how could fuel management be going down in these days?
So we increased the budget by $4.5 million during
journal appropriations. So that kind of changed the balance
and fuel for next year. So the original budget for fuel was $20 million.
We increased it to $24 million, but the FY 23 budget was
24 million and change. Okay,
got it. Thank you. Not due to more LNG or
electric cars or it's strictly that straight.
Okay. Council member, abbey Cayman. Thank you. And Director,
thank you for the presentation. I was hoping you wouldn't skip over
the last page as it relates to fleet electrification.
Really quickly off the top of your head, where are we
in terms of percentage of total fleet moving towards hybrid
or electric? In terms of percentage?
Let's see. We're still very small. We're making
incremental gains, I should say.
Council just approved the purchase of 97 vehicles.
We're getting ready to bring another package of roughly ten
vehicles within probably
the next month or so. One of the big issues that we're
dealing with when it comes to purchasing electric vehicles
is the limited capital budget that's available. And so
as I mentioned earlier, the focus on
capital and how we use that capital is on critical
equipment. So the bulk of the money is going to
police cars, fire trucks, and refuge trucks.
Whatever is left over gets allocated
to light duty vehicles. And that's where our opportunity is,
to fund electric vehicles. Now, what we're working on now
is we're trying to take advantage of the current used car market
and sell off as many underutilized city vehicles as
possible. We're using those proceeds to buy electric
vehicles now. And one of the reasons I'm asking
is, one is fuel continues to increase. We have
supply shortages, vehicles that are way
beyond their lifespan, and we need to continue to move towards the mayor's
goal of a renewable energy fleet.
However, I also know that the fire department, during their presentation
with their lease program for certain vehicles, is showing
improvements in returns on that. Are we considering that for other
parts of the fleet, city of Houston fleet? Yes, ma'am.
So, as I mentioned previously, we're in some unprecedented times here.
Vehicle costs, as well as the ability to source
parts to make repairs. We've got examples of
fire trucks that were damaged in accidents earlier this year
that are taking a year to 18 months to get repaired simply
because parts aren't available. And so
we have to start thinking strategically on how we
ensure that our emergency services are sustained.
And to that end, on top of that, we're having lots
of difficulty, as I've heard the other departments mentioned,
recruiting mechanics. And so as we
look at our current situation, we being fleet
management and our in house personnel focusing on that
critical equipment. And we do think there's going to be some opportunities
for increased leasing to help manage what's going
on with the light duty vehicles.
Let me back into you. Council Member Carolyn evan Shabaz.
Thank you, Mayor Brutam. Thank you so much for this presentation.
I just wanted to ask a question. Have there been any concerns
about the theft of catalytic converters? Have any
of them been stolen and are there any financial implications involved
with protecting them with the fleet? Yes,
ma'am. We did have a number of catalytic converters stolen knocking
on wood, but it has been over six to eight
months since we've recorded any thefts.
I'm going off of memory here, but I want to say that the city has
spent almost $400,000 in making
repairs to those vehicles that were vandalized.
Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman. Thank you,
Director. Do we know how many employees right now are utilizing our fleet share
program? I don't have that number. Off the
top of my head, I will say that over the past year,
we've worked very hard to get fleet share up. We saw numbers
drop dramatically during the pandemic,
and we're now starting to see an increase.
What we've also been doing is for our client departments
offering long term fleet share leases to cover their immediate
needs. Our purpose is to get as many of
the pool vehicles out in use, because they're not doing
anything for the city when they're just sitting. And so I
believe we're up, and I'll get back to you. But I believe
we're at 50% right now, which is
an improvement from I think we started somewhere around 30% earlier
this year. But I'll be happy to get those details to you. Thank you.
We'll submit all of these questions and a few others just to follow up in
terms of electrification process progress. Thanks,
Director Glascock. We have three public speakers here.
Our first will be Jason Oliver.
Good afternoon. Thank you all for the presentation.
I think the first question kind of going along with what Council
Member came in, was talking about, what's the kind of plan
to budget for electrical vehicle charging
infrastructure? I know that's going to be, of course, the electrification of the
vehicles is important, but also the infrastructure for
charging is vital as well. Right. So the purchase
of infrastructure to recharge the electric vehicles is made under the
capital program. We're also using the proceeds
from vehicle sales to buy chargers as well.
And so our idea currently is that we are going to need one
charger for each electric vehicle that we purchase, at least initially.
Okay. And then the vehicle lease program, what do
we know about the environmental impact of that? Because it
seems like while it might be cost
effective, it has a significant environmental impact that might kind of
offset what we're doing with the electrification.
Well, in terms of environmental impact, I would say that
the lease program has the same impact as
purchasing a new vehicle. And so basically, what we're
doing is pulling an older vehicle with
older emissions, a higher emitting vehicle off the street,
and replacing it with a newer vehicle. So I guess, in summary,
anytime we can replace an old vehicle, we're improving the environmental
impact, even if it's just being bought,
because it's like a year or so, right. With some of these vehicles
or the timing, so they won't be that old.
In many cases, we are replacing model year
2000 vehicles with these leases,
and those vehicles, when they were built, had much more lenient
emissions requirements compared to current year vehicles.
And so just in that switch out alone,
we provide for some environmental benefit. Got you. Thank you.
Saba Blanding.
Hey, good afternoon. I have a question
similar to Jason's, just in terms of environmental impact,
fuel consumption appears to be fairly consistent, around 10 million gallons
annually. And I'm wondering if you
all have any initiatives in place or proposed to significantly
decrease fuel consumption. Well, we do. We have
the targets of the Climate Action Plan to replace all
the non emergency vehicles with electric vehicles
by year 2030. And then we also have a vehicle
selection criteria we use. So when vehicle
purchases or leases are proposed to our department by
our client departments, we look at a couple of different things.
We look at the application, how the vehicle is being used, and then
we look at the market to see, is there an electric vehicle
available? If there is and it fits in the application,
then we make the decision to purchase that electric vehicle.
If an electric vehicle is not available, then we
look to the market to see if a hybrid vehicle is available.
And if there is, then we'll go hybrid. If we cannot satisfy
the application with either an EV or a
hybrid, then we purchase the conventional vehicle. Okay.
Thank you, Mr. Bernard Butler.
It's actually broderick like Matthew broderick.
Sorry. Thank you for the presentation.
And I don't mean to be critical. With all due respect, it was sobering,
but I appreciate the honesty of why
we as citizens walk around and see that Tesla
is putting fueling stations
in the HEB in Heights in Montrose.
And it's kind of amazing, right? He's not a city government.
He's richest man in the world. But for you
to tell me that you're not over 2% because we can't get to
this magical fleet of electric vehicles is very
sobering. I would think that the soon to be third largest city in
the country would have been leaps and bounds like Austin
or some other place like that. But that's
just a statement. I don't expect an answer. But I
am very interested in the second part when you said you don't have mechanics.
Well, in northeast Houston, where I am, we have a community college
that we need to have someone have a strategic partnership with
to teach young millennials to be actually
mechanics. And not maybe old school mechanics, but mechanics of hybrids
and fuel vehicles. So please give that some consideration going forward,
looking down the road. Absolutely. And I might add that,
in fact, we've got our Chief of Staff in the crowd here and we have
made some pretty significant strides in reaching out
to community colleges as well as high schools.
The high school mechanic programs have proven to
be very productive in finding and
recruiting employees. And so we're pressing very hard
with those learning institutions to try to get
anything we can to help us out. The only person got to compete with is
Chief Pena. He wants to be firemen. But if you get a couple of mechanics
out of it, not a problem. Thank you. Thank you.
And thank you, Mr. Glaxcock and Mr. Cruz.
This concludes a Fleet Management Department workshop. So we will
now adjourn for a second and begin our
budget workshop up on the Housing Department. Thank you.